when 9 11 happened  and uh uh everybody is looking around  saying wait a minute two planes that's  the enemy are you kidding me no problem  what are you black you're white i don't  care where's your kid i'm gonna go help  you yep you're republican you're  democrat i don't give a [ __ ] if you're  republican or democrat today we're all  americans right what happened the last  two years with kovit is  we said covet came and  say china's the one that caused a lot of  this rather than saying that's the enemy  we said you're a republican before i'm  an american i'm a democrat before i'm an  american we forgot the fact that we're  americans first before we're political  issues